this morning some families are setting
off on long overdue trips to this
country after pandemic trouble
restrictions kept them apart from loved
ones in this country for almost two
years starting today the u.s is allowing
international visitors who are fully
vaccinated to make non-essential visits
errol barnett is at the charlotte
douglas international airport earl this
news makes a lot of people very happy
this morning good morning to you
yeah you're exactly right gail good
morning airports like this one in
charlotte are already getting busy but
add to that the approaching holiday
travel season and international
traveling opening up and you can expect
things to get even more frenetic here's
the deal travelers from 33 countries
including britain most of europe and
china have been banned from traveling to
the us for about 20 months now but that
is changing as of today non-us citizens
over 18 can enter the country for
non-essential travel with proof of
vaccination this relaxed rule applies to
those entering by land or ferry border
crossing or by air if you're flying in
as a non-citizen you need a negative
covert test within three days of
departure or proof of recovery from
covert 19. now because of all of this
the department of homeland security
predicts longer border crossing wait
times airlines are reporting an increase
in bookings and check out these brits
traveling to the us from my homeland
there of england leaving heathrow today
excited to see their loved ones in
boston la and miami now american
airlines tells me it has some 20
international flights arriving here at
charlotte today and they say most of
those flights are booked solid this is
great news for the us tourism industry
but on the flip side tony that means
that we will have longer extended travel
wait times for the rest of the year
era will live with it you know they call
it non-essential but we're talking about
his family's reuniting feels pretty
essential to me uh thank you very much
appreciate it